الحقيقه ان هذه المساعدات هذه اللفت
الكريمه من خادم الحرمين الشريفين
تاتي للوقوف مع الاشقاء في سوريا وكذلك في
تركيا جراء هذا الحادث الاليم وهذه
الكارثه الكبيره الحقيقي لكل المعايير نعم
الان مركز الملك سلمان وضع خطه
للتدخل الانساني عاجل يركز على الاحتياجات
الاساسيه خلال المرحله الاوليه مرحله
التدخل الاولي او ما يسمى بالتدخل
الانساني العاجل هذه المرحله سوف تشمل
الحقيقه تقديم
سلام غذائيه او الحقيقه الحرص على تامين
الاحتياجات في مجال القطاع الغذائي كذلك
القطاع الاخر هو اولويه قصوى هو قطاع
الايواء تامين الخيام وكذلك كل ما يتعلق
بالحقيبه الايوائيه المعياريه التي يقدمها
عاده مركز الفنان خلال هذه الازمات وكذلك
بالاضافه الى ذلك الحقيقه حقيبه الدفء
الشتويه ليقدمها كذلك في الحقيقه في فتره
الشتاء هناك كذلك اهتمام كبير جدا
بالحسيادات في مجال الطبي تامين
الاحتياجات سواء كانت من ادويه او سواء
الوالديه او غيرها بحيث تسد الاحتياج
تساعد الحقيقه في نوعا ما تامين الاستقرار
للحاله الصحيه الى المتضررين في هذه
الفتره مع هذا الجسم مزوي الذي تنطلق باذن
الله عز وجل وتم تجهيز تحقيق الكبير منه
سوف يكون هناك فريق يقيم الاحتياج على
الارض بشكل ادق واضع كذلك خطه اخرى لتدخل
اثمر باذن الله عز وجل ولكن فريق مكون
فريق مكون من من يعني من مختصين اطباء من
من
الفريق الحقيقه يحتوي عدد من الجهات كما
تفضلتم فريق طبي الحقيقه يعنى بمجال
العلاجات الاسعافيه
والجراحيه هناك كذلك فريق من الدفاع
المدني للانقاذ ومتخصص في العقاب في مثل
هذه الحالات كذلك لدينا فريق لوجستي من
المركز سوف يقوم برفع الاحتياجات عن قرب
وكذلك
محاوله وضع خطه اكثر دقه واكثر شهور
لمرحله ما نسميها التعافي المبكر ولعلنا
كذلك باذن الله عز وجل نهدف الى ما هو
اكبر من ذلك نهدف باذن الله عز وجل الى
مرحله اعاده البناء واعاده تاهيل المنازل
المتضرره وكذلك اعاده الحياه الى طبيعتها
في تلك المناطق هذه المساعدات ستهبط في اي
مطار وستتوجه لاي مناطق
سوف اتحدث المطارات الاقرب لمناطق
الاحتياج بالتنسيق مع السلطات التركيه
وكذلك
السلطات المعنيه باداره هذه الازمه
والكارثه
طبعا قد تكون مرشحه المطارات المنشاه
المرشحه مثلا من اقرب هي اضانه اذا كان
صالح للاستخدام او ربما مطار انطاكيا وهو
اقرب كذلك من مناطق القريبه من الحدود
السوريه
الان هناك تنسيق جاري عليه المستوى مع
الجهات التركيه لعده امور الحقيقه اولا
كما تفضلتم الجانب اللوجستي الثاني
الحقيقه نتعلق بايصال هذه المساعدات
المتضررين في المناطق السوريه والتي تعتبر
تركيا هي المفتاح الحقيقه وهي المدخل لهذه
المناطق فهناك تنسيق الان على مستغيين
الحقيقه دعم عمليات الانقاذ وذلك عن طريق
الحقيقه دعم كل من يعمل الان على
دكتور افهم افهم من حضرتك بان كنت
تتواصلون مع السلطات التركيه لمحاوله
ايجاد حلول لادخال هذه المساعدات لشمال
السوري
وكذلك مع اي جهات في الحقيقه هي تملك
مفتاح للوصول لتلك المناطق
نتحدث كذلك عن حمله شعبيه حمله ساهم
للمساعده لمن هو بعيد
ويود ان يساعد كيف تتم المساعده لو نفهم
معك اكثر هذه الخطه
منصه ساهم منصه رقميه
تعنى اطلاقها مركز الملك سلمان من حوالي
ثلاث سنوات هذه المنصه الحقيقه فيها
محورين مهمين جدا محور المشاريع الثابته
التي يمكن ان يتبرع لها اي شخص يريد ان
يصل الى المحتاجين من خلال قنوات تبرع
البطاقات او غيرها كذلك لدينا المحور
الاخر محور اللي هو الكوارث او الطوارئ
الحقيقه نحن من خلال هذه المنصه بحمد الله
عز وجل هذه السنه جمعنا مئات الملايين
الفيضانات في باكستان فيضانات في السودان
وكذلك المجاعه في الصومال وما زلنا نجمع
ستطلق حمله من خلال هذه المنصه تمكن كل من
يريد ان يوصل شيء للمحتاجين ان يتبرع لهم
في قطاع الغذاء وقطاع الايواء كذلك القطاع
الصحي كذلك لدينا حسابات بنكيه سوف تنشر
وهي مشهوره حاليا على منصه ساهم ذلك لدينا
وسائل اخرى وهي رسائل الرسائل النصيه التي
يمكن ان يتبرع من خلالها الحقيقه ان مركز
الملك سلمان يحاول النصيه للموجودين داخل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
طبعا ولكن دكتور بالنسبه لهذه الحمله
لمنصه ساهم الحمله بدات صحيح يعني من يود
الان اتبرع هو قادر على ذلك
الحمله تنطر غدا الساعه واحده ظهرا باذن
الله عز وجل وسيكون لها تدشين اعلاميه
وتغطيه اعلاميه داخل مركز الملك سلمان
وسوف يكون عدد حضور من مهتمين للحقيقه
بالعمل الانساني وستكون الانطلاقه الساعه
1:00 ظهرا باذن الله عز وجل هذا فيما يخص
سهم اعود معك للمساعدات قلت لي انا هذه
المساعدات قادره على الوصول او يعني ان
تحط طائرات في المطارات التي ستجدونها
الانسب في اي وقت في غضون اي وقت
المفترض انطلق خلال 24 ساعه
الحقيقه تم حشد الموارد وتحريك الموارد
الموجوده في المستودعات نحن نريد ان نذكر
انه ليست المره الاولى التي نتعامل مع
يعني الجسور الجويه نحن اطلقنا عدد من
الجسور الجويه خلال كورونا في عدد من
الدول المتضرره حملت مساعدات كبيره جدا
كالاكسجين وغيرها من المستلزمات الطبيه
والادويه الى تقريبا 32 دوله كذلك نحن
سيارنا الجسر الجوي لباكستان جوي للسودان
وكذلك الحقيقه جسر جوي لتونس خلال ازمه
كورونا كذلك جسر جوي لمريقه
وخبره في الحقيقه س الاستجابه وكذلك
الحكيم من خلال الجسر الجسور الجويه وكذلك
لدينا مواد
لاحتياط دائما في الاحتياط موجوده نستطيع
تحريكها في اي لحظه في حال وجود هناك طارئ
او كارثه نعم بالتوفيق لكم دكتور سامر
الجصيلي المتحدث باسم مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه شكرا